so a fight actually broke out during
this movie right in front of me between
two women something tells me the movie
had them a little on edge due to the
fact that it was horrible sometimes when
I do my reviews I tend to wait a few
minutes while I explain the plot to tell
you how I feel about this movie I'm just
gonna say it right up front this movie
sucks
it's terrible please save your money
it's called house at the end of the
street it's this new horror movie it's
pg-13 it stars Jennifer Lawrence a
beautiful talented young actress who's
basically been in a string of very good
movies since a Winter's Bone where she
really got noticed Elizabeth Shue is her
mom and the rest of the cast is pretty
much unknown I'll sum up the plot very
quickly basically a long time ago in
this house that Jennifer Lawrence has
now moved in right next to a young girl
killed both of her parents and now the
son is living there and he's quiet and
he's estranged because obviously he grew
up with that you know all the pressure
from everyone because he's the weird kid
whose sister murdered his parents people
are disappearing random things are
happening this guy's there he's weird
he's a little strange but Jennifer
Lawrence is kind of falling for him and
who knows what's going on there those of
the shoe is obviously worried about that
because of his history but you're
supposed to feel for the kid he know cuz
he's grown up in this life and
everything and it's sad for him yeah
this movies really bad it's it's it's
it's pretty bad Jennifer Lawrence really
has no place in this film she's an
actress that is far above this material
she's proved that in the past something
went wrong with this movie for sure
because it is just so dumb it's on the
level of unscary that the apparition was
there's nothing in this movie except of
course maybe like 10 20 seconds of
absolute silence and then somebody will
grab someone's shoulder from behind it's
some loud boom of music and of course
Hutch just it's just your friend it's
it's no one this movie is the exact type
of film that Cabin in the Woods was
making fun of absolute horror garbage
with cliche after cliche after cliche
and an ending that makes absolutely no
sense
besides Jennifer Lawrence very poorly
acted Elisabeth Shue is looking grody in
this movie and I usually don't mind her
the way this film was directed it was
like he just tried to make every actor
in it look as worse as they possibly
could he keeps filming Jennifer Lawrence
like from below and everything from a
low angle
you can make anyone look like they have
a double chin from that angle and it's
like dude you are making your actors
look terrible learn how to film people
there's no scares in this scary movie
the ending is horrible most of the
acting is awful the only saving grace in
this film is the fact that Jennifer
Lawrence is clearly an actress way above
this material and she's giving what she
can to this movie but it's just so
stupid I'm not gonna spend any more time
talking about this movie the last thing
I want to say is that honestly they're
really honestly was a fight that broke
out during this movie okay these two
teenage girls over the left side of the
theater were texting and talking during
the entire film and finally someone
behind them said can you please turn off
your cell phone this humongous fight
broke out that ended up with those
people pouring soda all over the girls
behind them the police came had to
escort everyone out I had to give
testimony about what happened I mean if
this had been a good movie that would
have been really horrible for me
gracefully the movie wasn't good I
literally just sat there watching the
end of the movie play out trying to
figure out what was going on with a cat
fight in front of me crazy night I'm
kind of inspired to make a video about
the idiocy of people in movie theaters
nowadays maybe one day like I said just
stay away from this film I'm gonna give
house at the end of the street at
d-minus because of the talents of
Jennifer Lawrence just don't check it
out it's not even worth your time I
don't even feel like continuing this
review there's just nothing to say it
sucks
thanks as always for watching guys I'll
be back very soon with my review of end
of watch much better film I'll tell you
that
thanks a lot for watching if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]